welcome I'm going to talk to you today
about the Russ programming language and
about concurrency now I like to know a
little bit about my audience so I'm
wondering how many of you here mostly to
hear about the roast programming
language okay and then how much of you
here arm only mainly here for the
concurrency that's about half and half
so or actually and some of you raised
your hands twice I noticed that thank
you
but okay great well obviously there's
something for both to be there and
that's that's interesting to note I mean
obviously there's a lot of interest in
rust as a fairly new programming
languages and concurrency is always an
important thing to learn about well you
know something I know something about
you I'm going to tell you a little bit
about myself
[Music]
okay and I tell you a little bit about
myself so first of all I'm from st.
Louis right right here in st. Louis I'm
local and I work mainly in game
development and for the almost 10 years
now I've worked for Nvidia if you are a
PC gamer you've probably heard of nvidia
maybe it powers the graphics in your
computer and he actually does a lot of
other things including AI automotive
applications and all sorts of stuff but
what I work on is putting new tech into
game engines which means most of my work
is in C++ in fact I don't use rust at
all in my job it's C++ so if that's the
case why am i up here talking to you
about rust today well learning rust has
helped make me a better C++ programmer
and even a C++ programmer I hope to
convince you today that were near us
could make you a better Java programmer
or Ruby or whatever it is that you knew
and this is because resource really rust
really helps you get a clear
understanding of resources and ownership
and lifetimes which are concepts that
really exist in any language now why I
chose to focus on concurrency for this
talk of all the things I could say about
Russ is because it's it's hard and it's
worth doing now what makes it hard you
know concurrency is when we arrange our
programs so that multiple parts can
overlap that's the shortest definition I
can come up with for for concurrency so
as a result you don't know exactly what
order things are going to run in and
they're going to run in a different
order every time you run the program
perhaps so as a result it's really hard
to reason about what exactly your
program is going to do so that makes it
hard now why it's worth doing is that
concurrency of course can can unlock
speed ups for your program or or more
make your programs more responsive and
that's a better experience for for your
customers so that's
that's something hard and worth doing
now let's talk a little bit about what
makes concurrency hard as we work on it
first of all when I work on concurrent
when I want to make a program concurrent
I have to come up with a new algorithm
which is concurrent and so that's that's
work that I have to do but when I do
this it's not like a traditional
refactoring right I've you know we've
got a we've got to come up with of
course we're going to run our tests and
make sure our tests pass but the tests
don't necessarily save us it's because
we can't predict exactly what order
things are going to run in it's much
more common with concurrency to have a
problem that only you only find out when
you release it to production and 5% of
your customers have some problem right
that's not fun and so as a result we
have to use our brains to figure out if
our program is correct or not and you
know we only have so much mental
capacity if we're thinking about oh what
effect is this line of code going to
have on some other line that I wrote a
month ago or that someone else wrote in
some other part of my program well
that's that's a real heavy mental tax
for us and then of course this leads
back into now I've got less mental
capacity left over to experiment with
new algorithms right so it's a vicious
cycle and this is this is really you
know what IIIi think what makes it so
hard so you know what I really wish I
had when when I was working on this
stuff to start with is you know some
kind of genius expert sitting next to me
telling me when I had done something
wrong yeah quick feedback cycle right
instead you know what I had was staring
a debugger for hours trying to figure
out how in the world did I end up in
this state you know and or or all that
maybe just running something again and
again hoping to catch that that rare
error condition in a debugger so this is
you know what makes it hard now I want
you to push this slide on to a stack
we're going to pop it off at the end
after we
talked about rust but first I want to
show you an actual problem that I
experienced working on a game it was
about nine years ago I need to explain a
little bit about how the game engine
works here so in the game the engine
that I was working on there is a
rendering thread and the rendering
threads my main purpose is to talk to
the direct3d API direct3d or d3d for
short is a graphics API it's what we use
to put the pretty pictures on the screen
now now there are many things that
happen this I can't explain the whole
API but you know one example of
something the rendering thread has to do
is ask the sp3d for a resource in this
case I'm going to show a vertex buffer
or VB for short it doesn't really matter
what vertex buffer is or what it's for
we're going to think of it as kind of a
closed box most of the time we can't see
inside it we can't change its contents
right but we can if when we do need to
change it ask b3d to open it up for us
okay open up the box now I can look at
what's in there maybe I can copy some
new data and change its contents right
and that is going to be used to
communicate some data over 2d 3d now
when the box is open d 3d is not using
it to draw the pretty pictures on the
screen so you've got to close up the box
again before you ship it off and say
okay now use this and you give it a you
know about a billion other commands also
and together it uses this to draw one
frame of data on the screen this is not
not actually what the game looked like
but you know this is this represents the
picture so you know now the thing about
this is it has to happen 60 times a
second so you know about every 16
milliseconds we draw a new picture and
we do all the all these commands so now
you're all 3d graphics experts so so
let's let's move on and look at the
other thread that is of interest in this
so I have a novice writer I'm going to
call it the main thread and it does all
sorts of things but the
that I'm interested here is it simulated
physics
so it's simulated how things move around
in the world right and so every frame we
would take the output of physics and it
gets written to a buffer called the
simulation buffer so we make a new
buffer we write some data into it but we
want to use that data in order to update
the positions of the things we're going
to draw on the screen which means the
rendering thread needs it right so we're
going to move that data over to the
rendering thread now the rendering
thread can open up the dirt X buffer
copy the data in so that we can use it
to send off 2d 3d and draw the pre
pictures and because we're done with
that buffer we just throw it away and
we're done with it so that's that's
going to happen every frame of the game
and this works this works great so you
know here's our pretty picture whenever
we have something that works really well
in a game what do we do well we optimize
it right so we can't leave well enough
alone so the problem with this one is
that you know we've got the simulation
buffer and every frame we make a new one
we copy some data into it it copies some
data back out of it and we throw it away
so someone had the great idea well you
know couldn't we arrange it in some way
so that we can write straight into that
VB and cut out the no man alright so
I'll show you how we can do this better
version and this is the part by the way
to have the bottom so instead of a VB
being normally closed let's make it
normally open alright and let's arrange
for it to be accessible by the main
thread as well so now the main thread
when it runs its physical simulation it
can write straight into the VB and we
cleverly time things so that we can
guarantee this is not the part with the
bug we can guarantee that the physical
simulation is always done by the time
that the rendering thread needs to draw
the pictures on the screen so that means
we don't need any extra synchronization
no extra communication
between the threads that we timed
everything perfectly so main thread
rights whenever it feels like because we
know that's a safe time to write and
rendering thread closes up that box and
draws it whenever it needs it and it
just opens it up again and makes it
available for for the for the main
thread the next time so this works we
get our prey pictures on the screen and
we didn't need that temporary buffer and
we didn't need any extra synchronization
between the threads so this worked great
except very late in the development of
this game I got a bug assigned to me now
I'm going to show you a screenshot of
the bug so I know that most of you
aren't game programmers so to your
untrained eye it might not be obvious
what the bug is but the screens blank
and this is a really boring game nobody
wants to play that so yeah so this this
there was a bug in the implementation of
this and it was particularly bad timing
because this is back when people still
bought PC games off of shiny discs and
those shiny discs were already being
manufactured at the time so there wasn't
a lot of time to come up with a patch to
release by the time people got those
shiny discs from the store and you know
it turns out that this this bug was due
to us it was a certain kind of
concurrency bug called a data race now
we need to push this onto the stack as
well I will get back and explain it what
what the what the answer was what was
actually causing the problem at the end
but first I'd like to talk to you about
a little bit about what a data race is
explain that so in order to have a day
or race you need at least two threads
and you need some shared state and now
shared state is just some data that all
your bit multiple threads can see it
could be one byte
it could be a megabyte it doesn't really
matter conceptually we're just going to
think of it as some Sun box here that
that both of the threads can see so
let's look at an example of something we
might do here let's say that my shirts
say it starts out it's a strange loop
logo it's a perfectly fine logo but we
want to make a cuter so thread a is
going to write this adorable puppy to
the state and thread B is going to write
this cute kitten so the state so so
what's going to happen well it can't be
both it's gotta be either a puppy or a
kitten right well actually it's possible
depending on what happens at the
hardware level that you get some
scrambled state that resembles neither a
puppy nor a kitten so it could be
something that causes your program to
lose its sanity and do anything
unpredictable right you don't know
what's in there and it just depends so
yeah don't do that sorry
clicker troubles don't do that so yeah
if multiple threads write to the shared
state at the same time that's called a
data race so yeah let's look at another
example though here now in this case
thread a is going to write mr. bunny to
the state and thread B is going to read
this state now is this safe well you
know trying to be Mike get the strange
loop logo and then like it the bunny but
and this is a little more subtle and
maybe a less obvious but it's possible
if this write from a is not atomic
that it gets some intermediate state
right so it gets something that was
partially written and you know partially
not and so this is also not safe now I
said the word atomic there I should
probably define it right hey I got a
slang for that so atomic me
that basically if one thread accesses
state that all the other threads if they
read it they see something consistent
either they see what was there before or
they see something that was there after
but they don't see any kind of
intermediate state so normally most
accesses to memory aren't going to be
atomic that's because there's some
overhead associated with it you have to
do either some extra synchronization or
use some hardware support for it that
costs something it's it's so you can you
can pretty much assume if you haven't
done some extra work that your accesses
are not atomic and something like this
would lead to reading an inconsistent
state so this is also a data race right
one thread wrote another thread read
that's a data race now I've got a third
example here I've got this baby goat and
we all love baby goats thread am trying
being really low baby goats and I both
want to read the baby goat at the same
time what's gonna happen here is this
gonna work
well The Kids Are Alright
sorry that was my worst one of the day
it gets better from here yeah so so this
is so what makes this example different
from the previous examples well in this
case the state is immutable
now immutable means that the state can't
change right so you can think of this as
constant or read-only but yeah if if
something is immutable it means it can't
change mutable is the opposite me low
means it could change right and if we
can guarantee that things are immutable
if we can always make our state
immutable then we don't have race
conditions and that's great so yeah if
you want to see a language that take
that idea and runs with it check out
Haskell but this isn't a talk about
Haskell this is a talk about rust and in
rust as in most languages we think that
mule state does have its place when used
properly I do want to say Sarah very
long name SGP gave a talk just before
this new building the devil's garbage
collection so that's maybe another
reason you're going to use mu ability if
you missed your talk look it up online
afterwards I'm sure all these talk to be
posted so in summary race conditions if
you have more than one access so you you
access something from multiple threads
at least one of those accesses is a
right and those accesses aren't atomic
or you could also think of it as the
accesses aren't synchronized then you
have a data race all right I didn't
forget about rust and at least half of
you came here to hear something about it
so I'm going to tell you about it now
first of all here's hello world
everybody wants to know what that looks
like right so rust is known as a systems
programming language and people to find
out a little differently but the way
that rust folks think of it that really
means that you can access something
really close to the metal and you you
know without a large runtime without
runtime overhead that means you can get
something as low-level and
efficient as see when you and and when
you look at this you see you know curly
braces in semicolon systems programming
language it kind of probably looks a lot
like C to prove that that's not the case
I mean here's another function it
doesn't really matter what this does
don't get you know too scared by the
syntax but the point is must also let
you express things at a higher level
than you would with C and so you know
it's it's interesting for that it's also
known as a safe language it has a lot of
compile time checks compile time memory
safety so that your accesses to memory
you won't have memory leaks you won't
have like use after free errors and and
all the sorts of bad things that we
might have now garbage collected
languages also solve many of these
memory problems memory safety problems
but Rus manages to do it without garbage
collection which is kind of it's neat
trick so in basically Rus is known as a
language for Ryan safe and efficient
programs now I'm gonna give an example
here this function declares a variable S
assigns a string to it in rust strings
are dynamic so I could add something to
the end of this string for example so it
could grow or shrink which means that
there has to be a dynamic memory
allocation involved here so in a garbage
collected language such as Java I don't
have to worry about cleaning up my
memory when I'm done with it
also in roughs I don't have to worry
about cleaning up my memory when I'm
done with it but it works a little
differently in rust than a garbage
collected language
so here s has a a lifetime to it or you
could also think of it as a scope so
when s goes out of scope then the memory
that's owned by s is automatically freed
so the scope of a variable is going to
be the block that the variable was
declared in so you look at the curly
braces
and you know the last curly brace there
that was declared in is the end of its
scope that's the end of the lifetime of
s and so the resource s is lifetime ends
at the end of this function and the
memory is just automatically freed
immediately I shouldn't say I mean it
the compiler generates that code and you
don't explicitly do that right you don't
explicitly free that I want to show you
another example of something in rust and
here I'm going to open up a log file and
I you know left out that you can use
your imagination where what we do with a
log file we'd probably seek to the end
of it and write something there right so
there's a new key word here you haven't
seen before mute this is short for
mutable now remember earlier I said that
immutable data was safer right in rust
all variables are immutable by default
and that's because it's safer so the
safe choice is the default choice so if
you want to be able to change something
like a file handle because you want to
seek in the file and add stuff to the
end then you're going to have to declare
it mutable and then other than that the
in really interesting thing here is that
I have an open file handle and I want to
close it when I'm done with it
right and most languages you have to
explicitly close that but in rust it's
close for you automatically when the
variable that owns that resource goes
out of scope and that looks familiar
it's because this example is just like
the previous example is the same pattern
and so the key here is that memory is
just another resource a file handle is a
resource a network socket is a resource
and these are things that you probably
use in any language no matter what
language you're working on these these
concepts exist there's some kind of
resource that you have to manage and so
resources are kind of treated uniformly
in rust and resources are always always
have a clear owner
so I'm gonna show one more thing just to
make something clear in case it wasn't
in my previous examples here are this
resource lifetime function we're gonna
pass in a value if I passing true I'm
going to do some extra work I wouldn't
have otherwise done I'm going to create
a new log file okay and I do that inside
this if block now all my previous
examples showed something being a
resource being cleaned up at the end of
a function I just wanna make it clear
it's not the function but the actual
block that the variable is declared in
so that's the only real real point to
get from that alright so we talked about
resources and we've talked about them
being cleaned up in whatever block there
they're in but what if I want something
to live beyond that well if I want a
resource to live beyond the function
that it was created in that seems like a
useful thing to do so here I have a
function get strange it's going to
return a string and my string and my
string is in the variable S and this is
something interesting about rusts syntax
it may be familiar to you or not
depending what language you come from
but the return value of a function is
just the last evaluated expression in
the function so in this case s is the
last expression so it's just going to
return it you could explicitly say
return s but that's not it I am at a
trust so here this function just returns
the string now example is a function
that calls get strange and assigns the
return value to this variable strange so
thinking about this in rust terms this
memory resource that was created to hold
this string is owned by s first and then
ownership is transferred over to the
variable strange now strange is
responsible for cleaning it up whenever
it goes out of scope and then finally at
the end of example this in fact happens
so in rust even when ownership is
transferred it's always clear who owns a
resource and we we tend to think about
this explicitly in
alright now here's another function this
this one this one I'm going to make a
hello strange loop boring string but I I
want to I want to print it out a little
more exciting way so I got this helper
function type which is going to add some
exclamation points to the end and you
know really give it an enthusiastic
output to the screen now I call the
function first with in some enthusiasm
and then I print out the original boring
hello strange loop what do you think is
going to happen when we compile and run
this well compiler says no so what's
this about this is something that is a
little surprising when coming to Russ so
when you use this function call syntax
that you see here with hype it's either
going to copy or move the data into the
function and whether it's a copy or a
move depends on the type of the data I
don't really have time to get into the
difference and why there's a difference
here in this talk today so I'll just let
you in that string is in fact the a type
that gets moved so as a result when I
call hype ownership of that string is
moved into the hype function hello
doesn't own it anymore it's not now our
responsibility hype is responsible for
cleaning that up
now I've intentionally covered up hype
here with the error message we don't
just looking at this code we don't know
what hype does maybe it took that that
string and it's now you know moved it
off to another thread and that thread is
executing and doing something with
string so it could be very bad if we
cleaned it up at the end of this
function and that's that's where this
this this concept of moving a resource
comes in handy right because we made it
clear that we don't own it anymore the
compiler will make sure we didn't do we
didn't accidentally use this thing we
don't own anymore because that could be
unsafe so to fix this one way I can fix
it is to add a call to clone now I've
basically made a new string with clone
that has the same contents as the
previous string and I move that new copy
into hype
and this works it outputs hello a
strange loop
hello strange loop so that works but we
had to make a new copy just to call a
function and that seems like kind of a
pain so can we do better yes we can do
better so here's an example that calls
calls a function and we don't we don't
have to move the ownership now there's a
little bit of new syntax here so the
first thing is I have an ampersand and
press and that we read that as saying
that type is going to borrow yes so it
hasn't we haven't moved ownership to us
we've just kind of went it for a little
while and and the function type
signature for hype you see the it's got
an ampersand from the string now saying
that this is a string reference it's an
immutable string reference because
things are immutable in rust by default
so I couldn't change it but it can it
can use its value and so this works now
we've made a string we've printed out we
printed out the string with some
exclamation points and then we print out
the the regular one at the end excuse me
alright now I have a another there's
something really cool about borrowed
references that I want to point out here
and this is a bit of a contrived example
but it's kind of it distills everything
down to its essence so we can just look
at the main point here borrowed is going
to be a reference to s now so borrowed
type is a string reference and borrowed
is has it has is has in fact borrowed
our original mutable s strain so while
it is borrowed and while that borrow is
in scope we can print it out so we can
read it but we can't modify it we can't
we can't change it now here I'm not
actually doing anything with borrowed
but imagine if I were iterating through
the characters of the string and I had
gotten to say the L in the loop and then
I go along and I truncate that string to
five characters now I'm accessing a part
of the string with my
borrowed reference that it doesn't exist
anymore and that could be an error so
this is preventing us from making an
error I want to show you the the the
error message you get out of this so
this this kind of makes it clear the the
blue the blue shows you where the the
borrow began and ended and says hey you
did this bad thing in the mill oh that
you tried to change it I I did not
doctor this up at all this is a
screenshot from my terminal I love these
these air masses I'm gonna make the
camera guy unhappy but you don't have to
follow me if you don't want to but I
want to see this on a big screen that is
gorgeous is it is it wrong for me I have
these kind of feelings about compiler
error messages I mean I just look at
that anyway I love it I love that it
gives you such explicit and feedback so
yes so so this explains what's going on
um now you can think of this as you know
of course keeping you from doing on
something unsafe within within a
function but it also prevents a data
race because if this reference were in
another thread I would know with
certainty that it could no one else
could be writing to it and that's great
all right now let's go back to our
example with hype and let's make it a
little oh I'm sorry
first how do we even fix it if we move
the truncate outside the block of course
truncating it outside the block is safe
because the borrowed reference has gone
out of scope it doesn't exist anymore so
taking away the new ability if something
is not permanent right you get it you
get your mutability back once the once
the references to it are gone okay so
now let's improve height in instead of
printing something out let's actually
change the string we're gonna add some
exclamation points to the end of it and
then we're just gonna print out the
result so this makes it you know a
little more generic we could do
something else with it besides just
print it out using this height function
so when we do this you'll see there's
some more nuisance
here I've got an ampersand mute to say
that something is a mutable reference
and I have the type signature is amiable
string now it's a mutable string
reference and this works just fine too
so here again we're being explicit about
things more so than you may be used to
in another language but all these type
annotations and everything are what
allow the compiler to guarantee that all
this code is safe at runtime at compile
time and there's also a very cool thing
about mule borrows similar to an
immutable borrow but in this case when I
borrow something mutable II it is not
accessible at all which means if someone
else can write to my thing I can't even
read it because I could have the problem
from the other end they could be
changing it in an unsafe way that I'm
not aware of right and again you get a
beautiful error message with a that
shows you where the borrow begins where
it ends and hey you did this unsafe
thing in the middle right so this again
also prevents a kind of data race all
right putting all that together in
general in rust if you can read
something the compiler guarantees that
no one else could be writing it if you
can write something the compiler
guarantees no one else could be
accessing it at all and in the case of
borrowed references that's actually done
statically at compile time so you don't
pay any runtime overhead for this you
don't there's no runtime check right
there's there's there's nothing there
this is guaranteed and the compiler is
going to tell you instantly when you
compile it that you've done something
wrong this is how we get efficient
memory safety without garbage collection
but this exact same features also gives
us a compile time guarantee that data
races are in fact in
possible in rust alright um there is a
downside when you learn rust a lot of
people feel like kind of the compiler
kind gets on their nerves at first a
common complaint is that you know it
makes you it forces you to be really
explicit about lifetimes about ownership
of the your resources in ways that you
didn't have to in other languages right
and this is you know it is some kind of
friction but I'd like to flip that
around if you are doing safe concurrent
programming you need to care a lot about
resources and ownership and lifetimes
and the russ compiler is right there
teaching you to do that so when I say
that rust has made me a better C++
programmer this is one of the things I'm
talking about in fact it's one of the
main things it's that I think I've just
gotten a very intuitive sense for
ownership of resources in my programs
it's just become more natural because
when you get to that point where you're
not fighting with the russ compiler
you've internalized it right and so the
concept of resources and ownership and
lifetimes applies to any language if you
don't even have to have multiple threads
I mean there's unsafe things you could
be doing even within a single thread so
my whole my whole take on this and what
my whole point here is that it's worth
learning even if it's not what you're
going to use in your day-to-day work
okay
popping something off the stack remember
this this error we had before in the
rendering thread the rendering thread is
managing a bunch of resources right and
it's making calls in 2d 3d well at some
point it makes a call to D 3d and it
gets a fatal error and what does that
mean well now all your graphics
resources that you had are invalid you
have to throw them away and you have to
create new ones
and the renovator knows how they do this
that's this isn't a problem and every
game has some code to handle this sort
of thing that's not really the big deal
but what happened in the case of this
optimization was differed different
ideas between the two threads on what
the lifetime of the resource is so the
rendering thread thinks that the
lifetime lasts until it gets a fatal
error of d3d
and the main thread thinks the lifetime
lasts well at least as long as physical
simulation is running and you can't
really have two threads with a different
idea of what the well the lifetime is
without a confused idea of ownership so
you know when when you look at this you
know it's obvious that each thread
thinks it owns the resource because they
each have their own idea of what the
lifetime is and so I really wish that
the person who had made this
optimization had learned Ross now that's
impossible because it hadn't been
released yet at the time that the code
was written but my point is that if they
had they would probably had a bear
intuitive idea that what they had was a
mixed case of ownership and there was
probably going to be trouble down the
road
and they might have designed this a
little better now I'd like to say that I
made this safer because it is in fact
possible with a little bit of extra work
to make this say this optimization safer
but actually given the short time
constraint I just removed the
optimization and that got the game out
in time now popping the next one off the
stack remember this one things were
really hard to test right hey if we take
if you decide to go a little beyond what
I'm suggesting here and actually start
writing your programs in Russ not just
using as a tool to learn some skills you
get compiled time checks they're
preventing some errors and that's pretty
cool that removes a whole class of
errors you don't now you don't have to
worry about them and as a result your
mental overhead of having to work on
current programming has gotten really
teeny tiny so tiny you can't
my writing and so as a result you've got
more mental energy left over to
experiment with new algorithms now I'm
not going to say that rust solves all
the problems you can still have
concurrency bugs in rust but it
eliminates a whole class of errors and
let me tell you in my experience at
least in games data races are the number
one problem you have so it's pretty
awesome that rust takes care of this at
compile time all right one final thought
here there's a list of five languages
every programmer should learn if you
search for this online you'll find it
the only problem is nobody can agree on
what those five languages are and and so
you know all I ask really is that you
take your five languages whatever they
are and you address to the list if you
do this then we can still be friends
can we all agree okay so here's some
resources to get you started and that's
all I got today
thank you very much
[Applause]